right now we're experiencing a
resurgence in intolerance nationalism
racism you were a reporter an active
reporter and you were in the midst of
the civil rights movement you covered
dr. Martin Luther King I did and you
just mentioned the Klan one of your
assignments was to go and attend and
report on a Klan rally a several several
several planned rallies and I think
that's a perspective that first of all
that must have been I imagine that would
be a frightening experience to have had
at the in in the 1960s you're part of
the media and you're at a Klan rally of
scary stuff I first say so but all I
could think of Conan during and after
that time was a fear that I felt that
taro had a Klan rally what it must have
felt like for families of color to have
those runners happening in in their
neighborhood and what did parents tell
their children so whatever fears and
concerns I had paled by a comparison of
knowing what it was for families of
color you mentioned before that this is
the first president we've had that has
waged an active campaign against the
media we've had other presidents and
political figures kind of take a stab at
that well in all right George Wallace
when he was running for president in in
68 and 72 would often use the trick of
saying a lot of reporters here but
they're not going to report on what I'm
really talking about because they're
from the New York Times and they lie
they did it Nixon who you reported on
you reported on throughout the entire
Watergate scandal used to talk about the
media and try and distance the American
people from the media but you think
Trump's taking it to a whole new level
well the facts show that he's taken - oh
yeah quite right Trump has taken several
pages out of George Wallace's racist
campaign yeah of 1968 and own in 1972
and make no mistake
President Nixon disliked to a point of
hate the press and he did have a system
of trying to intimidate press people but
out of his own mouth nothing compared to
what President Trump is right that's
these personal attacks on individual
reporters you remember
when he ridiculed the reporter who had
physical challenges disabilities and and
saying that these press people or
enemies of the American people this is
very dangerous kind of language it's
reminiscent of authoritarian regimes in
other countries and one reason the
subtitle of what unites us is
reflections on patriotism you know
there's a difference between patriotism
and nationalism we don't go into deep
conversation about it here but
patriotism is willingness and dying for
your country love you country but
recognizing its mistakes and it needs to
get better paper nationalism is more
beating on your chest saying we're super
everybody in the world it's a it's an
important difference well nationalism
will destroy us eventually you know that
patriotism is actually caring enough as
you say to you know about the system and
trusting in democracy there's elements
of nationalism that are that are treason
but no Connor you have a extraordinary
young audience and nobody wants to talk
down to it but I do think it's important
that they understand that always talk
about nationalism that economic
nationalism extreme economic nationalism
in the 1920s that is a Great Depression
racial nationalism Arian nationalism led
to Adolf Hitler and we want to be very
careful of going too far in the
direction of nationalism and not far
enough in the direction of patriotism
you